do you have advice outside of all this
discussion to
young people today about career about
life since you've done so many things
you've
overcome a lot of things i think high
school college student
thinking about what to do in their life
do you have advice for those guys
and girls yeah yeah
first is you don't have it figured out
so don't worry just jump in
yeah um we talked uh you know a lot
about uh understanding your values and
aligning all that stuff
but you gotta have a base level of start
exploring and learning
and uh just spending the time doing like
pick something let me elaborate a little
bit
no you know what a lot of people
struggle with that aspect now because
the choice
there's so much choice it's difficult to
pick something but i think it does boil
down to
you should pick something and don't
worry about it and then but
within that you can start discovering
the things
that are there for you like i i talked
about i made this huge shift i threw
away a whole life
but i don't regret anything about that
i wouldn't be where i was if i didn't
walk through and learn those things and
in fact
in the course of that i learned just how
much
that inspiring people and helping them
realize the potential far beyond what
they thought was capable and guess what
that was leadership 101 in managing
people base level
floor level right and i got a lot out
it was perfectly aligned with and that's
what i realized it didn't matter
what industry i was in or any of those
other things
but i was able you can see so many
things there's so many paths that you
can go down to help you
realize what those things are and you're
going to be able to find
a lot of those nuggets and develop those
do you think that i could have just
gone to school and got out and
started a globally recognized brand
within a few years
without having been schooled in
business while getting paid for it by
others
for years and in fact that entire time i
knew that that's what i wanted to do but
i didn't go out on it
i mentored some of my friends along the
same path
to go no they're like i'm ready i'm
ready to go do this and i'm like no
now you need to go get a job you yeah
you know engineering management design
all that stuff
go get a job as a as a manager now like
oh that's a step down i can't do that
i'm like go try it a couple years ago oh
my god that was such a good move
i didn't know what i didn't know and now
they're an executive for freaking a
fortune 500 company
and the same thing like i sat there
knowing that i was getting a free
education
don't stress yourself out as my that's
my advice
don't stress yourself out that you've
got to have this perfect thing
because this process of understanding
your values in the interest but that
takes time
you can get a job where you're getting
paid to learn
exactly that's a good deal before you
launch on your own
you